en el carácter la nueva reina es el
combate llamado kumite tres minutos para
elegir entre dos rivales las técnicas de
mayor espectacularidad son las que más
puntos dan todo lo que es técnica de
puño a punto la técnica de pierna al
cuerpo son dos puntos y la técnica de
patada a la cara son tres puntos además
en lo que son agarres barridos llevar
contra el suelo a su adversario seguido
de una técnica de puño también dan tres
puntos
la segunda prueba en tokio es la cata
cada atleta recibe una nota atlética y
una nota técnica que cuenta por 30 y 70
por ciento del total y karateca está
solo ante siete jueces
el kata es una serie de técnicas
codificadas en el vacío contra
adversarios e imaginarios hay que ser
precisos rápidos potentes y también
hacer un buen trabajo de equilibrio
[Aplausos]
el carácter un arte marcial de defensa y
de contras significa el camino de la
mano vacía es originario de china pero
fue desarrollado en la isla de okinawa
el karate moderno surgió en japón a
comienzos del siglo 20
el kárate es uno de los deportes más
practicados en japón creo que se va a
escribir una página de su historia
entonces sí va a ser algo extraordinario
lo que vamos a vivir allí que cosas de
extraordinario a pesar de 40 años de
negociaciones la historia del carácter
en los olímpicos será breve y el comité
ni la carta estarán presentes en parís
y la pelea ha sido difícil desde 1980
hasta hoy y lo de 2024 ha sido una
terrible decepción son solo 80 atletas
no es mucho no se necesita mucho espacio
quiero decir más allá de un tatami es
algo que se hace fácilmente tras los
torneos de kata y kumite cuatro hombres
y cuatro mujeres obtendrán un título
olímpico una oportunidad única de marcar
la historia de los juegos